you're from Florida I don't look Tampa
Tampa okay Tampa curious do you if are
you living here and you know lay then
you get home a lot oh yeah I get home I
was home just recently like this summer
where I was listening to mark my parents
getting old too
yeah and my dad just started eating
marijuana because he's got a bad hip
uh-huh and you can tell because you
start saying dude all the time he's like
dude have you listened to Pink Floyd
dude you're like it's like getting high
with a ninth grader yeah so the last
time were there my mom goes I'm Albert
why don't you take Burton the girls out
to the dock and talk to your owl I'm
like dad talks to an ALICE she goes
every night he talked to that my dad's
like dude it's amazing so he goes out me
and my daughters and I like what and
nothing it's late at night it's dusk it
always does yeah okay nothing and my
[ __ ] daughters are like Papa should we
try I'm like that don't courage him so
then the three of them are out there on
the dock like like three crypts let them
know cops are in the neighborhood so
finally good dad I go dad I don't think
you're Al's out we should try this again
tomorrow he's like it's crazy he's
always out so we start walking in the
second our feet touch the grass off the
dock we're whoo and I am if I get chill
bumps I'm like dad you're a Latinos I
told you dude get up to the edge of the
dock he goes oh and sure enough right on
top of it my oldest daughter hits me on
the hip and goes dad look at the old man
on his dock
[Applause]
you know about that story both of them
are happy yeah don't know sheesh I don't
know never tell them they have it now
wouldn't you love to have it now you can
talk to everybody
you